l'écran où s'affichent et des infos
liées aux chroniqueurs et à la police tu
vas devoir deviner quelle anecdote
correspond à celle à quelques
chroniqueurs c'est très simple alors
regardez c'est parti je me suis fait
flasher en décidant de double et en
double c'est en double et évêché vais
très très con ça alors je sais pas qui
c'est mais comme ça après le oui non
mais écoute comme une salle commune ça
va tu aimerais frings et il ya très
longtemps quand et avec freddy flamand
un peu après parce que tu te raconter ce
moment là j'aimerais mais comme toi ça
paie la dream team
ouais ouais ouais non il n'est pas à ce
moment-là il passait son temps à me
casser hamshahri mais c'est aussi jouer
il voulait mettre des tard face à sela
mais maintenant que c'est comme ça mais
oui c'est vrai mais ça s'est passé pour
clavecin j'étais un peu con alors ils
sont si nombreux à main et je le dis je
le dis franchement benjamin je vous jure
moi j'ai découvert un mec c'est
tellement tout le contraire de ce que
j'avais en tête c'est madame j c'est le
mec qui sont fous de tout il peut avoir
une voiture exceptionnelle il peut voilà
être sûr d'avoir veut il fait qu'ils
sont fous non mais c'est ça et c'est
pour ça que je t'aime je suis assez
content dans la vie en fait mais c'était
il faut pas le faire mais j'ai eu un
flash en fait c'était en suisse en
revenant de lausanne et je voulais
vraiment double le tgv j'ai une belle
photo avec avec un beau avec un bon
chiffre non combien va-t-il au 309 309
dont c'était la marque de la voiture
sinon 309 pas fait 309 km est voilà donc
benjamin fois c'est ça surtout pas car
c'est un gamin mais on les aime c'est un
gamin mais il faut surtout pas qu'il a
peu refait n'ai jamais jamais plus et
ben jambes et surtout avec les voitures
kotama même attention
c'est sur les aspects vous dire sur tf1
là ça y est c'est vrai qu'un jour tu as
acheté tachetée de tafer jeter quoi ils
d'aston martin j'ai eu le coach direct
comme ça en fait j'ai fait un truc
magnifique chez les infantes a gelé voir
casino royale et était donc sur les
champs elysées
et ça c'est un luxe énorme et je vois le
film et je vois la bagnole hd mais
qu'est ce qu'elle est belle et jolie
mais il ya un magasin ashton qui dont la
furia côté là et je sors du cinéma genre
dans le magasin je dis bonjour dray dans
la voiture de diallo demande s'il vous
plaît
non j'ai kiffé non mais franchement je
ne regarde pas mais s'évade succès
magnifique souvenir péage au nirvana et
la paille ont comme ça après gilles j'ai
pleuré quand j'ai revendu mes mais sur
l'enjeu c'est très heureux alors
regardez j'ai chauffé policiers pour
éviter un pv mi-mars calais je dis moi
je dis je dis est jeune et manille non
c'était fini tiffany c'est moi si j'ai
bien compris
normalement si la production est on est
dans le match ils sont fidèles à la prod
et à ses 8 ans le mot chez troc est
alors tu vas dit que ça fait mais je
vais me prendre une amende et là je fais
un peu l'ingénue je vais faire je vais
chercher mon sac dans le kop je sors les
jambes et je t'ai balancer cheveux il me
dit alors non seulement ça n'a jamais
marché ça va pas marcher et en plus vous
êtes pas du tout mon genre non à jeter
des routes et là j'en ai pris un coup
sur les rails venait d'arrêter castadi
a320 n'était pas mise à jour c'est quoi
le plus gros kiff que t'es fais toi
voilà castany la vie son rêve s'est dit
tiens je vais aller j'ai pondu une aston
comme ça à un kiff
non mais plus plus gros kiff cesser les
cascades que j'ai fait dans 30 jours
maximum et le style vraiment qu'ils font
parce que pour le coulage il ya une
séquence où je suis en moto et je fais
une course poursuite en une touche de
slalom entre des voitures à 100 km/heure
dans paris et sa maman en temps normal
je parle de le faire mais là j'ai pu le
faire c'est un kiff c'est toi qui as
fait c'est moi qui ai fait et sans
casque j'aurais pu mourir for my hand
ces actes avec tata flipper impôts bas
j'étais très concentré parce que je
savais que je pouvais peut-être ne pas
rentrer chez moi mais c'est vraiment
surtout que je venais de passer le
permis moto exclure ça
bon bah écoute heureusement il s'en est
sorti il est là où nous voulons aller
vite
normalement donc remet tait s'il vous
plaît à yves roger demander leurs
papiers aux policiers si nicolas par
nicolas et moi j'étais suivi par les
services secrets non ça c'est la vraie
vie je ne crois pas que ça se voyait ben
oui alors oui excusez moi
salut tu vas bien fait a remarqué le
principe c'est honteux j'avais 25 ans et
en fait je me suis fait arrêter à 6
heures du matin je sortais de l'aquarium
qui était une boîte de nuit et je me
suis fait arrêter par une rigole pas ma
saksik à taxi qui m'a fait une queue de
poisson et kalil giropharm dernier
moment et j'ai pas cru au fait que
c'étaient des policiers
donc je me suis renfermé la voiture et
j'ai refusé de sortir la voiture et j'ai
dit et montrez moi votre matricule
montré moins truquées les mecs ont eu
tellement ras-le-bol ou le 15 minutes
qui m'ont laissé partir
bah c'est pas la meilleure anecdote non
mais c'est sympa quand même si j'ai été
suivi par les services secrets
ukrainiens mais je pense que dans vg je
me suis fait arrêter car chanter trop
fort je pense que c'est kelly ça oui
c'est moi arrêté sur les changes faire
servir ils vous ont pris pour gilles
verdez alors c'était avec des copines
mal en soirée on chantait dans la
voiture je pense que je chantais un peu
failli à l'aquarium bonjour nicolas
pernikoff sûrement on allait au pacha ah
oui en banlieue fallait y aller le dis
toujours oui je pense que j'étais là où
il y avait les soirées sexy oui c'est
vrai dimanche soir vous avez l'air de
bien connaître alors que dimanche soir
sachez le avant quand les discothèques
est ouvert c'était le meilleur soit
parce que le lundi les coiffeurs ne
travaille pas les boulangers et
boulangers gens qui travaillent pas
lundi donc le dimanche soir c'est la
meilleure soirée
je connais un petit peu jetteraient des
baguettes gyrophare tout ça on
n'entendait rien et on a continué
jusqu'à la boîte du coup ils sont sortis
ils nous ont arrêtés à l'entrée de la
boîte et on leur a dit qu'en fait tout
allait bien et juste heureuse de sortir
en fait on criait tellement fort que les
gens s'inquiétaient et se demander bas
ce qui nous arrive
et au final c'était la fin du service
ils sont partis se changer et sont venus
on les a gentiment attendue non avare
d'amendé pour tapage nocturne et nous on
dit pas si vous nous attendent et on
rentre on vote avec vous nous qu'on les
a attendus en iran droite avec bravo
belle histoire belle histoire un quart
est merveilleux c'est vrai il emboîte
totem bien danseurs rarement un stand
ans je suis un boucher un bon danseur ça
va je me débrouille toulousain bat l
avec toi allez vas-y aller batailler
cool
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
servant le pacha le dimanche soir elle
et cherrier temps normal on voit paré
sexe et services secrets alors on va
faire que ce qui nous intéressait gp
show policier qui m'a sauvé c'est qui
c'est géraldine toujours pas c'est vous
mais oui mais non mais non mais quelle
j'étais vous avez les combats n'étaient
pas plus et vous c'est quoi ce policier
[Rires]
s'est quand même raconté mme de france
est au lycée des eaux claires à grenoble
on était embêté par une bande de garçons
dilution de drague fait pas partie des
boycotts ils voulaient nous draguer un
jeune policier qui je ne demande d
strictement rien qu'avec à 30 plus que
nous est arrivé en disant une foutez lui
la paix c'est ma soeur n'ont donc là il
m'a pris d'autorité sous son aile et
après on est sortis ensemble au lycée un
jour j'arrive des [ __ ] t'as vu c'est
la fille qui couche avec son frère c'est
comme il s'était fait passer pour m'en
faire mal du coup toute l'année terminal
gnl et la fille qui couche avec son
frère c'est quand on atteint là lendl
isabelle non les mecs ont ainsi
peut-être un policier m'a convenu avec
une star c'est qui a confondu avec
christophe lambert
non eric martin lambert avec un ami en
voiture et ont été contrôlés pour excès
de vitesse et lucky luke donc ils
commencent à nous verbaliser nous mettre
l'amande et en moyens des deux qui
disait vous êtes dj sneak non oui c'est
moi jai c'est moi une tiare j'adore
votre musique et s'était arrêté à celle
ci succès disney après pixar
et c'est par mail annonce voilà